hi i'm carter morgan and today i'll be
talking to you about api first
application development
whether you're adopting cloud services
or transitioning to a cloud
infrastructure
an api first approach can help you
manage the complexity of developing new
applications
let's check out how
[Music]
as organizations are increasingly
leveraging cloud technologies to build
applications
they implement processes to orchestrate
new microservices architectures
containerization and continuous delivery
but where do they even start when
developing a new application
as the first step they need to make sure
that the data that will be powering the
application is exposed as an api
the developer is responsible for the
rest of the application will be the
first consumers of this api
this ensures that the application has
the quality predictability and stability
to withstand web clients mobile users
and other developer consumers
but although apis help you unlock
innovation in order to accelerate it
organizations need to rethink their
workforce to expand their application
development bandwidth
their traditional code first approach
application development sometimes
results in delays rework or disjointed
experiences for end users
additionally there is a large growing
deficit of developers in the world
and as a result it organizations are
experiencing a huge backlog of software
requests
slow development cycles and security
challenges
because of this organizations are
adopting no-code application development
solutions along with an api first
approach
to empower their line of business
workers to build applications within the
guardrails prescribed by it
why you may ask well there are several
benefits for choosing this approach
first by decoupling internal
independencies from the back end to the
front end
work can progress faster and
independently
next by showing only the necessary
details of the intended users via apis
we hide the complexity of connecting to
data and services
and lastly leveraging a no-code approach
allows companies to quickly create
high-fidelity prototypes and gather
feedback for end users
and iterate now let's talk a little bit
about how you can leverage apis to build
applications without coding
using apogee and app sheet you can
easily connect to existing apigee apis
within app sheet
customize applications and deploy to
mobile web and desktop interfaces with a
click of a button
this shortens development timelines
considerably let's look at a quick demo
of how this works
we're going to start in the apigee
environment where we have an open api
specification
an api proxy that represents that spec
and an api product which publishes the
api proxy for client applications to
consume
today an app created in app sheet will
be our client
in our hipster products api proxy we can
see a pre-flow policy that checks for an
api key
this helps to secure the api as only
apps that have this secret key can
invoke the api
next we can see the api product that
publishes the api for client
applications to use
called hipsters silver
at the bottom of the api product
definition we can see that an app has
been registered already for app sheet
and this is where we get the api key for
our app
now we're going to switch personas we've
been an apigee api producer up until now
in app sheet we will put on the hat of
the line of business user
the first thing we'll do is create a
data source to point to our api in
apigee
we'll click on plus data source to add a
new one
we will name the data source apigee
hipster's demo and select the apigee
type
we enter the api key from apigee and the
url to the open api spec
and now we can validate and then
authorize access
to create the data source next we can
create an app
we will go to the my apps area app sheet
notice that we don't have any apps yet
so it's assuming we want to create one
we do
we'll use the start from your own data
option and the data will come from our
apigee api
we'll call this app hipsters app now is
when we get to choose the apigee data
source we created
i'll select apigee hipsters demo let's
select products
appsheet just created the app for us and
we can see the preview of the app in the
pane on the right already
we need to just make a few adjustments i
know that there's a picture of each
product in the data
but it's not showing up we'll change the
picture data type to image
the product id is kind of ugly let's
change the app to not show that
and then it will show the product name
first let's save our changes
now the images are showing up and the
product names look great
appsheet helped us create our first app
within a minute
this is how you can easily leverage
apogee apis to build no code
applications with appsheet
in summary the apigee data source for
app sheet gives you an easy way to
leverage your existing apis to develop
no code applications within app sheet
by abstracting data and services as apis
and using these apis to build
applications without coding
organizations can accelerate development
timelines considerably and reduce their
application backlogs
now it's your turn to try it out and get
started by clicking the links in the
description below
[Music]
you